we have voicemails that we answer some
voicemail questions before we move into
the lightning round but today we're
going to sort of merge the two segments
together it worked really well last week
when I brought my two doctors in from
nourish balanced thrive and we had a
chat and and so we didn't have any
voicemails specifically about access we
had a lot of social media questions so
we're at the minimalists on all the the
socials and we have some questions here
today let's start with our our first
question it is from Emily Emily asks
ownership at its core has to be an ego
thing right um when I walked out of my
garage this morning it's all my
neighbors new g-wagen and the garage I
got my 2004 Toyota Corolla they're there
I definitely like look at that I'm like
you gotta be an egotistical person to
have a freakin gy I can't thinks I mean
I think III think if you have the money
for a something like a Mercedes Benz
yeah SUV it's somewhat like a piece of
art yeah I'm kind of projecting you
because I wish I owned a g-wagen I mean
there's beautiful engineering there but
uh the truth be told a brand new Toyota
Corolla is probably more reliable sure
in terms of its engineering and you know
the Six Sigma that goes into the the
design and and also the the the
manufacturing the the sort of repetition
has to be good to produce that many of
one product now Ryan I don't know if you
think that there's ego involved in this
why not when I think about ownership I
think there's there certainly necessary
ownership and what we're not saying here
is you shouldn't own anything and you
should just only have access to things
that's that's a weird sort of dystopian
communism and what I like is you've
provided a market solution to this this
problem that we have of both
overabundance and also lack of access
yeah at the same time and I don't know I
think sometimes maybe ego is involved in
ownership
I think definitely is our way I hope to
see things move is where it turns into
the things that you own you have pride
in those things and a help
and so you know I think about when we
talk about like helping people own the
things they want to own if you're really
into art or sneakers or whatever it is
like that's great you should pursue
those things but you shouldn't also feel
like you have to own a drill and a
ladder and you know a boogie board and a
surfboard and a drone and all these
other things you should be able to get
access to those things whenever you need
them and so I don't know I do think I do
think in its worst form it does tie to
ego but I also think there's a positive
side of that that probably taps into a
similar motion around pride of buying
quality things which I talked about a
lot yeah which I'm a big proponent I was
like research finding great things and
then you know buy those things instead
of buying the junk that is gonna be
thrown away in a year yeah I totally
agree like it is owning stuff
egotistical like as a blanket to say yes
like that's not true right um but
certainly yeah the bad side of it it
certainly can be egotistical I think for
anyone out there who's like asking all
you know it my you got cystic oh by
owning this one thing I mean you've got
to ask why are you owning that one thing
is that person owning the g-wagen
because they really do find the beauty
in the art yeah and you know they go
off-roading a lot and they have all
these these value adds to their life
from owning a g-wagen not to mention it
is a beautiful this is a beautiful car
or are they owning it because they're
like yeah I'm the [ __ ] yeah man look at
me I own a g-wagen I'm awesome look how
rich I am right like maybe that's what
it really boils down to is do I own this
so I can say look at me or do I own this
because I truly get value from yeah and
if you can sort of parse that out and
maybe sometimes it's both and then that
can be a problem as well I mean you and
I both drive Toyota's and I'm sure I
could go finance a more expensive car if
I wanted to but I really don't want a
car payment so I could you know find a
way to to afford that Mercedes Benz
g-wagon but why because it wouldn't be
for me in that case that's interesting
so if you at what I heard you say and
I'm not saying that this is true but it
might be and you know I don't I don't
want to say the majority of the time but
maybe if you are taking a loan out on
something like a G Wagon uh-huh it's it
probably might it might be an
egotistical move right because if you're
financing something to when there's a
substitute
you can use that is is gonna allow you
to not finance it I mean you might ego
might get a little bit involved there
because I know like my 2004 Toyota
Corolla dude I look like a long-haired
hippie driver
he's a 2004 Corolla but it surfboard
rack right exactly I don't care what
people think of me and my 2004 coral
sure but a lot of people do like they do
want to they do care about other
people's thoughts and if we're buying
something or financing something just
because we are concerned how other
people look at us or we're trying to
impress someone
yeah financing might be might lean
towards that ego side I don't does that
make sense yeah what I would say is I
don't care what you think about me I
care what I think about me and the same
thing is true with with the material
possessions my car is newer than yours
and it's I don't have anything against a
2004 Toyota Corolla but I prefer to have
a different car from what you have and
there's nothing wrong with it but I have
it for me it's not to impress anyone
else I don't care what anyone else
thinks all you drive a Toyota like I
live in a building where there are a lot
of BMWs and Mercedes and they are pieces
of art I mean gee wagons there yeah well
yeah they're definitely quite a few of
those and there's one that's that's
camouflage but I haven't seen it yet
done yeah and and and I guess I think
that's the same thing is true with with
our stuff if I if I am owning something
for me because I truly get value from it
then I don't think there's a part of the
ego or at least the bad part of the ego
where I'm worried about that if I'm
trying to impress other people or
impress upon them what I am this kind of
person because I own this widget and we
can remove cars from the whole thing for
a second think about this for a second
the average American throws away 88
pounds of clothes a year and yet we
continue to go shopping for more clothes
and and not just shopping like oh let me
take some cash in my pocket I'll buy
this shirt no let me put that on the
Banana Republic credit card I'll open it
up and save ten percent I'd be stupid
not to do it and and it becomes this
weird thing where it's like oh I'm
trying to impress upon you this image
as opposed to saying oh I really like
this shirt because it fits me well or
feel I feel good in this or it's simple
or yeah this is how I get value from it
as opposed to man I really hope this
impresses someone else been reading that
book
retired inspired by Chris Hogan yeah he
talks about fake rich and he talks about
how he's like you can live your whole
life like being fake rich and then
really regretting it like when you don't
have any retirement savings or you know
you can live a meaningful life you can
you know cut out the extra expenses and
save for retirement but you know I think
that's another thing too it's like are
you are you know are people buying
things to be fake to look like they're
rich should be fake rich in the short
term which I know we talked about this
on the podcast before the lake Ryan it
it totally boggles my mind why do people
want other people to think they're rich
like I don't get it it's because a it's
gonna attract the wrong type of person
who I mean if they're coming at me just
because I'm driving a G Wagon for
example well then that's the part that
really right exactly do it what that
relationship
you know guys who buy really nice cars
so they can impress women it's like is
our lose really the type of women you
want to bring into your life a woman
that's gonna judge you just for the type
of car that you drive hmm so yeah it's
it's interesting to me why people even
go out of their way to be fake rich well
it reminds me is I we got this tweet on
the minimalist account and this lady
said something about what drives me
crazy is always feel the need I have to
wear really nice clothes so that so the
men will like me oh and I'm like a real
man really doesn't give a [ __ ] what
you're wearing I'm if he likes you he
likes you for you and it's not about
like oh well I would date her but her
heels just weren't high enough man that
sweater was too orange for me a lot of
the pressure that we feel we think we
feel it's not someone else we're just
projecting that pressure on oh it's like
a self-imposed pressure that's a good
point yeah yes sometimes
you